[Music]
Federal Trade Commission is warning
taxpayers about a new and growing tax
scam pay attention identity thieves
stole at least one point six billion
dollars in tax refunds in 2016 a CBS
News previously reported scammers
typically pocket URI fund before you
file the IRS calls his latest scheme a
new twist on that old scam so after
filing a fraudulent tax return criminals
deposit the bogus tax refund in the
victims real bank account CBS News
financial contributor Mellody Hobson is
here to explain so all the sudden some
money turns up in my bank account and
I'm thinking yeah it's not not mine I
mean these criminals have gotten so
sophisticated it is not so this is the
money in my account and then what
happened first of all they file a bogus
tax return using some real information
from you keep in mind the Equifax breach
put tens of millions of people's
information out there including real
Social Security numbers in certain
situations so they filed this bogus
return but the twist is the money ends
up in your accounts then they call you
pretending to be the IRS badger you say
they're going to file criminal charges
say that your social security number is
going to be blacklisted unless you send
the money back to the quote IRS which is
them and the bogus return that they file
is bogus but but the IRS thinks it's
real that's right and this is really
important because this means the IRS
only sends one tax return personal
security number so if you've gotten a
return if you are owed a real one it's
tied up now you are not going to see
your real return until this whole thing
gets sorted out which is a nightmare
they filed a bogus return in your name
yes violet as you as you the action
pretend they're you they might use your
real social security number likely do
they spoil this return and you get a tax
refund but this isn't even your actual
return so what should you do if this
happens so the first thing you want to
do is you want to call your bank if the
money ends up your in your account and
tell your bank to send the money back to
the IRS the ACH Department automated
Clearing House that goes back first
the next thing you want to do
immediately call the IRS and explain to
them that you have received this money
in your account and you you were you or
not it is not supposed to be there so
that's where you start because once that
money hits your account you are legally
on the hook for it from the IRS
it's amazing how complex they're not
just stealing your number and then
charging up a bunch of clothes and
having a great weekend I mean this
requires lots and lots of steps to you
know it requires vigilance now on the
part of all of us my big rule of thumb
no incoming nothing if someone calls you
if they send you an email the IRS does
not operate that way they send regular
letters first snail mail the
old-fashioned way so if you're getting
anything like calls or emails you want
to hang up the phone do not respond to
some tax preparation service that sends
you a link bad idea but these phone
scams must be working because they're up
over a thousand percent and it's not
just phone it's email as well as I as I
said so you might think you're going to
an actual tax preparation website it
might be a bogus one so you want to
hover over the links to make sure the
site is real operate on secure sites
only alright Mellody Hobson keeping us
safe yeah thank you melody